Fire Emblem fates birthright is the
perfect game for newbies to the series
gameplay isn't easy but it is forgiving
with multiple customization options for
difficulty it also presents a story that
isn't complex so much as it is heartfelt
and although the writing can get
melodramatic at times it does elicit
genuine bursts of emotions frustration
anxiety sadness it's all there
built neatly onto the framework of a
strategy role-playing games stuffed with
tactical puzzles that yield satisfying
results in short it's everything you've
ever loved about Fire Emblem with a
handful of new mechanical twists and
works birth rate begins with your
customizable protagonists heading out
with your four siblings on a mission for
your father King Garon of noir but
surprise you're actually not their
sister but a royal daughter of the
hoshido Kingdom a neighbor at war with
noir after a brief skirmish you are
reunited with your hoshido siblings and
given a magic sword for being sent out
into the battlefield here you are given
the choice of three separate narrative
paths and if you pick birthright then
you've chosen to remain with your blood
family and fight the people who have
raised you talk about biting the hand
that feeds you this sounds like a really
cheesy premise but it creates a canvas
on which some truly affecting moments
occur birthright follows the time-tested
Fire Emblem format of turn-based battles
playing out on a grid you move your
characters like chess pieces weighing
their strengths and weaknesses against
your enemies when engaging an enemy the
bottom 3ds screen will display how their
weapons stack up to yours as well as the
potential damage you inflict on each
other and you can also highlight any
opponent to see their range of movement
this is exceedingly helpful when
planning out moves especially when
you're looking to protect weaker units
birth rate also emphasizes that same
kind of unit placement introduced in
awakening we're placing units next to
each other will often allow them to team
up and get a few extra hits in on
enemies
selecting from your dozens of fighters
and coordinating your assault is a
delicate dance and forces you to agonize
over every move it's a special kind of
anxiety that makes you feel
accomplishment with each battle one like
untying a particularly convoluted knot
while birthrates maps sadly don't have
much variation the plethora of
activities you can do back at your home
base do the my castle feature allows you
to build a strongholds complete with
armories a mess hall lottery shop and
arena as well as your private quarters
where you can get more intimate with
your recruits and boy can things get
intimate as units fight together in
battle they can build up a bond that
makes them a better team on the field
and in the sheets if it gets strong
enough offspring resulting from these
unions will show up in optional
side-quests called paralogs this feature
made me feel closer to my team as all
units are given the opportunity to speak
with one another in the support menu
which tracks their budding relationships
often I would find characters roaming
the grounds together harvesting daikon
or running the mess hall then I would
come home to my husband and do
ridiculous things like rub his face and
blow on the 3ds mic to stir up bath
steam this gives you a deeper connection
to your people which adds to the lovely
theatricality of the story and makes it
that much harder to see them fall in
battle you can play a few ways in
birthright if this is your first Fire
Emblem Phoenix mode is a wonderful more
gentle on the nerves addition that
allows you to experience the story with
minimal agony Phoenix mode resurrects
your fallen units after every turn which
also allows them to survive nearly every
battle and keep all experience points
and items they earn this along with the
scouting feature makes the grind easier
scouting randomly generates optional
challenge missions on the world map
giving you the opportunity to spend
extra time levelling certain units or
preparing others for Parenthood scouting
allowed me to not only level up when I
was too underpowered to progress the
story and also spend time forging
relationships between certain units in
this way I could bring my army up to
snuff with minimal fuss and also have a
simplified way of breeding my army of
super strong children all three fates
games also let you drop the difficulty
mode at any time if things get a little
too much for you so if you're easing
into the fates experience or if you only
care about the story and the romance
stuff birthright is a great start but
compared to its sister games Fire Emblem
fates conquest and revelation birthright
gives you more access to resources and
allows you to recruit more units so many
people want to help you and you'll have
a variety of heavy-hitter and spell
casters at your disposal I like to my
embarrassment of riches because it
allowed me to tinker with my characters
classes and weapon sets as well as buy
them cute accessories or make them walk
around in bath towels it really gives
you the feeling of running a small army
as you tend to their emotional and
physical needs but
in and out of combat did I mention at
any point that your avatar can also turn
into a dragon I didn't because it
doesn't matter turning into a dragon and
combat gives you a bit of a physical
advantage in physical attacks but not
much and after your initial
transformation in the story it doesn't
acknowledge your weird habit ever again
it makes the whole schtick about you
being the chosen something or other feel
cheap and its glaring lack of importance
highlight some of the other cheesier
melodrama of birthrights
like subplots about treason and your
childhood best friend whom you forgot
but the melodrama works for birthright
especially in the context of the
building a ragtag army to take down a
despotic leaders story fire emblems
over-the-top portrayals of heroism love
and sacrifice add drama to fighting with
sprites on a grid and in birthright the
cheese is turned up to 11 it's pretty
great
if you loved its predecessor Fire Emblem
awakening you'll enjoy the heightened
tension and intimacy imbued in every
moment of Fire Emblem fates birthright
between the strategy that dating sim
elements that can help but swoon over at
melodrama and some truly gorgeous
visuals and music you can overlook
things like repetitive maps and
cringe-worthy dumb parts of the writing
the series that kicked off the strategy
RPG genre still has it and you'll enjoy
getting wrapped up in the conflict